morning andy
okay something is different about my
computer
aha
it's gone
oh
a game is the foot see part of the
police academy entrance exam is
investigating a crime so about a month
ago i told everyone in the office that
at some point they should steal
something from my desk so i could
practice
let's do this
wait hey do you guys take my glasses too
i got my sunglasses too
i was in miami last weekend i took my
talents to south beach how do you spend
your time in miami maybe fencing stolen
computers yes i took your government
computer from indiana
to miami to sell it on the black market
for 150 bucks
you don't know it but you just gave
yourself away
been looking at your file all day
jerry if that even is your real name
it's not my real name is gary well
gary
if that even is your real name somebody
stole my computer now if you're a
criminal look at me
you have to tell me legally
or else it's considered entrapment
i'm sorry andy
it wasn't me oh man oh really well
okay yeah okay so we know it's not jerry
uh unless
he was lying to me i can never tell when
people are lying to me
hopefully that doesn't come up in my
police work
chris traeger
yup hi andy
i know you did it did what
don't play stupid and handsome with me
you stole my computer so that i could
practice for my police exam
you're as guilty as you are sexy annie
another computer was reported stolen
from the offices on the other side of
the courtyard i don't think this is part
of your police training
i think city hall was robbed i can't
tell if you're lying to me really i
think like a real crime that's even
better
what's the play here officer are we
gonna set up a perimeter maybe bug a few
phones ooh i know we could put out a
dummy computer for them to steal fill it
with explosives first
boom take them all out
yeah we're not doing any of that andy i
love your enthusiasm but we don't really
have the kind of money to launch a
massive investigation
you're just gonna fill out this stupid
report and that's it as a future cop you
have to understand i cannot let this guy
go look man
this is what most police work is
just writing stuff down it's not
superhero time
if it sounds boring
maybe i had to do something else
maybe we should find the person who
stole his positive attitude
good morning colleagues co-workers
friends
everyone feeling normal
today here's what happened i left my
sweatshirt at ron's cabin when i went
back to get it i found this
in the trash positive pregnancy test
side note i accidentally threw my
sweatshirt away that's why i was digging
through the trash i found that too
pretty cool so if my science is correct
one of the five women who are at the
cabin leslie donna ann
mona lisa or april is pregnant
can't be april
she would have told me that leaves four
suspects
there's only one man for this job
bert macklin
fbi i said i was retired they said i was
too dangerous for the pawnee police
department turns out they were right
and wrong
macklin
you son of a [ __ ]
oh hello
ann oh boy what do you want macklin me
just observing a little something they
taught us down at quantico
well i guess i'll get out of your hair
wait there is just one more question
congratulations is that a question it's
an accusation cause i know your secret
you're pregnant what i'm not pregnant
you're not damn it who is cause i found
this uh ron swanson's camp is a
pregnancy test oh my god someone we know
is pregnant i'm trying to get pregnant
that's not fair i mean great and happy
for them and congratulations whatever
but ooh no boo we have to find out who
this is no i don't think so bert macklin
works alone i will buy lunch you can
have as many burgers as you want welcome
to the fbi
how many people am i talking to
donna one or one and a ninth are you
asking me if i'm pregnant
oh
interesting i don't remember saying
anything about anyone being pregnant are
you sure
it's not you i'm a grown woman with a
good head on her shoulders don't worry
about me
this case just got interesting well not
just it was pretty interesting to begin
with this case just remained interesting
my assistant has something she'd like to
show you
partner
oh my assistant has something she'd like
to show you partner
it's a positive pregnancy test tom i
found it outside of ron's cabin after
our brainstorming sesh is there any
possibility mona lisa could be pregnant
we always use protection
i'm pretty positive she pokes holes in
them what brand pregnancy test is it
it's called womb there it is that's her
brand
i'm gonna be a dad
i'm gonna have a baby with john
raphael's sister oh god what have i done
like to humanity change is good i guess
not to me leslie's going around asking
everybody if they're better off than
they were a year ago
all i care about is that i'm the same if
i'm the same as i was a year ago i'm
happy wait i forgot
who the hell is pregnant what i found a
pregnancy test at your cabin and i
checked with all the girls who were
there it wasn't any of them
hello darling what a surprise hey
can we talk maybe in private
oh
a few days ago in a routine campaign
stop in downtown pawnee one leslie knope
paws was attacked
play
by a pie
luckily it only hit jerry so no damage
was done play the only evidence we have
is a video shot by paws my wife
april ludgate this is burt macklin's
greatest assignment yet if you are
watching
perpetrator
just know
that you are still at large
okay listen up folks we have a security
situation here as you know when we reach
location i will be conducting a security
sweep also from now on we'll be using
code names you can address me as eagle
one and code name been there done that
april is currently doing that
donna is it happened once in a dream
chris code name if i had to pick a dude
ben is
eagle too oh thank god
i've been staring at this board for days
i'm so close to putting it together
there's got to be something we missed
let's go over this again
the video shows that the pie came from a
high angle
so it would have hit your face
like this
mm-hmm don't close your eyes
no no it actually was from up higher
is that about right
yeah
good
clean yourself up let's do this again
all right let's go to the video again
sweet kick leslie exits the building and
then you get hit
what else do we know
we know that leslie was about 15 feet in
front of you
so clearly the assailant has terrible
aim
or
leslie wasn't the target
well who then
okay that's permanent marker go find ben
get a list of everyone he's ever fired
go go
macklin
you son of a [ __ ]
sewage joe
ben white fired you for sending pictures
of your penis to everyone and you've
come here to pie him little twerp has it
coming oh dude i dare you please
give me one reason to take you down i
would love nothing
oh
ben sorry all right let's go
oh
i did it
yeah
great job
you